il premio cesso della settimana va
allora quel fallimento del digiuno
ricordo come si chiama alternato il
fallimento della vita di questa
settimana mi sento di panarea questo
molto quella data è stata adottata al
fine di non so cosa devo farcela
non esiste rivelare uno studio ricoperta
non esiste sta riorganizzando le idee
perché nella pena chiamata tra marco ed
enrico che hanno lanciato una nuova
sella questo nuovo talento sarà di non
farci la doccia per una settimana
comunque ragano lo sta diventa una
follia sta cosa che guglielmo bandisce
challenging praticabili gianmarco e del
rigo bandiscono salento ancora più
praticabili quindi vi chiederei una
cortesia commentate qua sotto e datemi
l'idea per la mia c'è l
mi sto allenando in casa nostra
iniziando già sputare vorrei capire che
cosa dovrei fare
anche questo allenamento che sarebbe
anche uscire di corsa a infilarmi nel
video intero o devo farcela
sono dell'idea che dopo il fallimento
della scorsa settimana io debba in
qualche modo dimostrare di essere
affidabile di non essere un buffone ha
quindi impegnerò intanto marino enrico
stai lontano che non sente degli 1 vitor
e perché sono pilota al meglio che fa
tante le condizioni di odore stanno
peggiorando nel tempo mi illusi che sta
lavorando lì che a distanza di rosso
durante la quarantena in fatto un bel
record
complimenti con l'unica differenza però
che era aprile cioè non faceva neanche
questo caldo perché noi stiamo sudando
fa caldo
guarda ormai e quelli di parti fuori
della pelle dura che non riesco a
sfidare tocca regista un altro boghetto
per dare il buon esempio a guglielmo che
propone le challenge non le rispetta
stata rispettata linea secondo me è
proprio sta facendo come gli pare
secondo me comunque lui sta facendo il
furbetto
me lo sento starà girando le regole i
buoni propositi
oggi è così beh ragione ben tornata
dovresti fare una cosa per noi
dovresti annusarci le ascelle perché se
no il pubblico non ci crede che non ci
laviamo da giorni ma giù la mia privacy
serve il parere femminile per questo
canale
[Risate]
[Musica]
complimenti alzate la maglietta e un po
andava lentamente nuova io so e ci
stanno e scatoloni e lo stendino che
ogni inquadratura ero scena e mezzo ci
sono io ricevo capire se veramente anche
solo uno di noi ha fatto questa sfida
almeno una volta sono poi i giorni che
continua a lavarmi entra in cui la mente
non ha senso proprio per me cioè una
sfida area o tappa oggi mi sono andato a
pezzi in cui è presente adesso sto per
andare a pallavolo
quello che sono fradici di sudore che
faccio non mi lavo aspetto con una
macchina passi su una pozza m fradici
per lavarmi no ok settimana senza fare
la doccia
fortunatamente piove dai e ne approfitto
per farmi una bella doccia
non credo sia evidente che l'eccellenza
dei miei cugini non facciano per me
allora vogliamo dire una cosa già marco
appena chiesto ragazzi ma ve la state
facendo la cosa della doccia la vittima
tutti gli altri seguendo non
assolutamente un primo momento morso il
video io manco morto botta a 3 celle
insomma no ma so pazzo siamo appena
tornati da circuito di vallelunga fa
dalla giornata faticosa e impegnativa
abbiamo sudato
diciamo che la cosa ideale sarebbe farsi
una doccetta ma io dico che in realtà
non è strettamente necessario
la pelle ancora reggono l'odore che ci
crediate o meno
l'odore ancora regge e quindi ragazzi
sono stanco morto e la doccia amo
aspetta considerazione così al volo ma
lasciamo stare le sole tre di notte
sotto ornato al lavoro faccio pagare
cioè nel senso o sudore rappreso addosso
che potrei togliermi come se fosse
ceretta e togliermi la barba così una
nostra paura io che cos'è che dovrei
fare secondo loro fila testa in
lavastoviglie farne un di decoratrice
carmi con i gatti con cap non lo
sapranno mai data bagno 3 di notte da
anche a pazzesco proprio per queste una
di quelle celle non ho intenzione
nemmeno non di vincere ma forse no in
termini di partecipare io non ci credo
che noi veramente stanno facendo sta
roba qui domani lì annuso vediamo un
pochino
per le andando in bagno come in bagno ma
perché a casa tua non c'è il bagno che
stai facendo
ma come dagli arti cavetti la loro
intenzione anche di ma come ti puoi
tagliare non lo so macchinetta e va male
senza la parte ii e non fossimo una
settimana della dolce non possono armi
dice tu vuoi attaccare il tetano vi
adoro sterilizzare quindi il problema
non puoi lasciarmi questi mettiti una
mano sul cuore di tagliare di più il
codino il codino e non si può più
tornare indietro
per far ciò che è stato la condanna è
segnata cosa ci manca per lo fa male se
temesse tirando lo scalpo perché sono da
un nodo pazzi senso a bravo tiratina
matteo gozzi ragazzi perché se non hai
scampo
santo cielo che ansia per roma
ti spiego come facciano i minareti qui
ho due nodi questo sarà un gran problema
quindi non si fa ai capelli per tagliare
lì bisogna cavalli in più mettici che ci
stanno pure i nodi a beppe lì poi lava
nel lavandino
andiamo avanti così io pure ne questo
che li guarda shall così in top line lei
ma lei massacrato mai fatto uno scalpo
importante
sono appena tornato da pallavolo
ed installa una chiappa bloccata vorrei
tanto in tanto tanto tanto per tutto il
male con il colore voluto la mia tarda
età a buttarmi sotto la doccia una mista
sentano in colpa
questo saperne coltello fra i ragazzi
escono meta volevo capito stanno
cercando di seguire questa sfida quindi
un giorno solo che sarà stasera proprio
norton non fare la doccia e lavarmi in
maniera alternativa commesso il mio
bellissimo costume iniziano così i
capelli di lago nel lavandino
non c'è l'atalanta sta davanti non posso
fare la doccia quindi rimane solamente
lui
peter biblioteca 32 anni posso armi vola
testa del bidet e culturalmente non è
successo e scaricare a sto punto
no non posso lo trovano molto di motivo
oggi via bagno guarda per terra senza la
minima competenza e abbandonate è uno
schema
eccolo anzi questo è devastante con
spazzola ti devi tender il capello e
tagliare è la base del barbiere
non possiamo nota io stavo a portare
quelle da cucino io comunque non si
ebbero entro uno spettacolo indecoroso
di punta devo andare riservato di punta
abbiamo trovato una soluzione a tutti i
nostri problemi trama senza protezione
qui c'è un odore vedete bando ha
polverizzato ti fai varco vista sarebbe
un male cane vero no
ma sì comunque ceri dei bagni perché mi
sento un cosa servano le agenzie storico
di generazione ci pone prima di lavarsi
una testa in convenzione se fossi stato
in francia mi sarei mai potuto lavare la
testa nel dire vedete quanto inutile in
realtà il video
questo punto la prospettiva di una lo
sto pensando il corpo non posso fare non
è vita questo vuol dire che devo trovare
un altro posto al mondo linea finisco
qua dimostrò che cosa voglio fare
tutti i sensi mi sento più sporco di
prima allora ultimo aggiornamento se
abbiamo usato il balzo che devo parte
mia ma siamo sicuri che non pulisca in
realtà in realtà è un sapone ammorbidire
i capelli ciao scusa ma perché entri
lascivo sembrava ricade sul tavolo sai
sempre imposta far accorsi se la natura
per farlo macchinetta dovresti aver cd
asciutti forse ci siamo
anzi il diffusore ma che fa
[Musica]
marco messeri di non aver inserito dai
acqua e asciugarle reporter imbeccano
questa è la mia idea
utilizzerò due ciotole da riempire con
acqua calda
queste due ciotole toys e non mi bastano
queste io non potrò più rientrare in
casa perché gronde roba da riempire e
vediamo che succede
questa qui è tutta l'acqua e posso usare
il bagno schiuma credo che questo sarà
uno dei momenti più bassi della mia vita
dire che di momenti bassi ne ha avuti
iniziamo non mi piace questo spaccato
[Musica]
spero che questa roba non ricreare la
categoria porno se piuttosto nella
categoria patetico la dr taglio con le
forbici era pensata gliel'aveva
macchinetta adesso che abbiamo altro
l'orecchio e 9 non lo vedi novità c'è
ancora ma quello che non ha fatto una
chiara
vabbè donne in questo ci danno una
marcia non ce la fa non solo questo noi
ci stavamo scervellando ma perché non
paga perché non taglia abbassato la
misura non tagliava affinché già mappa
rosario che la barba famiglia la
macchina questa è una macchinetta per la
barbati o con questa la barba eleva a
occhio no no che porta
e lei fa per godere monnezza cioè guarda
che cosa ha fatto allora lì va bene che
stai a 0 in realtà non c'è sono le
basette se non c'è la criminale certo
c'è fa per danno qui guarda quanto come
ho chiesto prima ho fatto ma si può fare
senza quello è tuo ma come detto certo
ma non più che mi tagliate e ha capito
ma tesa io adesso marchio io in realtà
pensavo di farti una cosa tipo questo ci
sembra che questo è la riga è tosta
della modella la piacciamo qui in testa
a che tipo di scodella una scusa nasco
dell'aperta giusto che ne fa il giro e
vediamo che succede
ragazzi avete presente con meno vede e
adulti che se più piccoli in e voi ne so
vedi che ventenni eto'o dicevo sono
proprio grandi che sta che faranno nella
loro dieta alcuni questo numero lei è
basso questo perché freddo quest'anno
[Musica]
secondo l'ultimo colpo ciao
ci dobbiamo dare una ripassata però
almeno diamo un'idea di quello che è la
parte che ciò qui una scodella dietro
come cioè solo pure abbastanza
soddisfatto è concreto c'è un pazzo come
dico non è più quella roba in testa cioè
per carità ora è ancora un obrobrio in
testa quello quello proprio che non c'è
più non posso farmi la doccia e che
siamo già ad un evidente non si può fare
la doccia poi affidarsi a gianmarco per
questo che vertiginosa che siamo
arrivati veramente intero e disperazione
mai più ma paiono non sono un barbiere
si è quello guidato ma capace così fai
bene come poi dei biglietti non stavi
facendo più alto è come non è tolto
niente che faccia come te la senti
l'espressione rassegnata guerra eccoci
qua ragazzi quello che potevo farlo
abbiamo fatto stavo da un'ora e mezzo ai
10 di voi di fare barbiere
mezzo napoli e genna toccherà pure a me
antitaglio io ragazzi sono sconvolto e
rico dove sei tu e il tuo cosplay da
coatto
però io mi giustifico mi hanno messo le
mani in testa
a me sembra che più che prendete arresta
per lo ha preso per il culo sentito
tanta personali mairin tenero con la 64
ma ora cacchio autore c'è un odore di
cristallo dietro questo e capone vero
mamma mia
oggi stanno facendo dei saponi è una
cosa stiamo facendo insieme a raffaele
riuscirà più avanti e ne adopereremo
subito uno come supposta per tutti e due
proprio a lento rilascio la linea noi
continuiamo a esserci lavati vero no no
etico e gusto se ancora i dello zio era
nel momento di decretare il vincitore ma
che se conosco processo shirt col della
settimana usa nella 7 no sono pazzesco
potevi fare meglio in aziende o potevi
fare meglio ma non ha messo in dubbio la
sentisse di per coprire in giro così
certo è che oppure fatti da chi sia
piena di 24 26 alzato la stessa nazione
abbiamo un'idea qual è l'animale in cui
sublime all factor ap il cui sublime
olfatto gli permette di conoscere
qualsiasi caso quando mai
l'olfatto del gatto utilizzeremo un al
fatto di piatto da temere chi ha vinto
per un motore cambio per capire del
gatto perchè anche la pila attorno a
cardano due gattini cuccioli ecco
casualmente o due volte due gattini
assolutamente
[Musica]
i conti sentite quanto feto ragazza
sentita ragazzi avete una responsabilità
enorme
questa è una faida che va avanti da una
settimana settimana quindi a noi il
giudizio buy
ok che vinca il che puzzolente sarà un
po più plessi assoluta luglio
indesit ha finalmente è solo perché sta
annunciando la toccato diretti legge
direi che ha detto guglielmo ragazzi
ragazzi sarà solamente cercando di
scendere questo caos non contestare il
metodo di giudizio dei nostri giudici il
premio cesso della settimana va
guglielmo gm jean marc 5 lo sai perché
hai vinto
secondo me perché enrico adulto sale
balsamo per tagliarsi i capelli perché è
perché hanno da quanto è risaputa casi
pulisce ma non vorrei essere cattivo ma
io ho usato praticamente il balsamo ogni
sera sono sempre allenato non ho seguito
niente e vado pure a casa col trofeo ha
meritato ragazzi di tuoi fatto schifo
no alla domanda ragazzi se per voi
enrico avrebbe dovuto ricevere questo
premio
mettete un like a questo video 90 rai
enrico rita questo premio perché non ci
credo che lo stanno dando non ha proprio
senso smetti di discussione da chi non
si mette in discussione quello che
faccio le cose ma mette in discussione
la giuria ma andiamoci a fano doccia dai
che io mi faccio veramente schifo
vado a farmi una doccia ciao